And my name is Seth Priebatsch.
I'm the chief ninja of SCVNGR.
I am a proud Princeton dropout.
Also proud to have relocated here to Boston, where I actually grew up.
Yup, Boston.
Easy wins.
I should just go and name the counties that we've got around here.
So, I'm also fairly determined to try and build a game layer on top of the world...
...and this is sort of a new concept, and it's really important.
Because while the last decade was the decade of social...
...and the decade of where the framework in which we connect with other people was built,...
...this next decade will be the decade where the game framework is built...
...where the motivations that we use to actually influence behavior,...
...and the framework in which that is constructed...
...is decided upon, and that's really important.